[Musique]
aujourd'hui au salon un service public
de transport un service public de
transport auquel nous sommes
particulièrement attachés au Sénat
service public présent dans la cité et
les cités de notre région
d'île-defance a service public qui
dessert dans toute la France ça n'est
pas les RATP mais qui dessert les
communes les boursentes les villages et
c'est donc un hommage au service public
que nous avons voulu rendre
aujourdi RTP est un grand service public
un service public de proximité hein
chaque jour nous transportons sur nos
nos réseaux franilien plus de 11
millions de personnes notamment ici dans
cette belle station Luxembourg
et ce quiillustre la cérémonie de ce
jour c'est que c'est un c bien sûr de
transport de mobilité comme on dit
aujourd'hui mais c'est un service public
très intégré à la ville il est très bien
je trouve que les les stations sot en
correspondance avec leur environnement
immédiat ici évidemment notre très
illustre et très glorieux voisin c'est
Sénat c'est aussi c'est un peu la même
chose mais le jardin du Luxembourg que
les Parisiens bien au-delà connaissent
et fréquente
assisumement ce sont les trois questeurs
qui en 2019 avec moi-même avont souhaité
que participer j'allais dire à la mise
en valeur de cette très belle station du
Luxembourg qui portait le nom du Sénat à
partir de l'année
2008 monsieur le Président mais qui
n'avait pas la signature totalement du
Sénat cette signature on la retrouve
ici la République notre tris couleurs la
démocratie parlementaire qui tranche par
le vote et le rôle que doit jouer dans
un état de droit la démocratie
parlementaire vous voyez la balance
l'état de
[Musique]
droit